كشف اهم جواسيس السوفيتي لدى الغرب وقدم
تنبؤات مستقبليه عن الاحداث العالميه
المهمه وفيما كان ضابطا بالاهتمام في
الاتحاد السوفيتي اصبح مواطنا امريكيا ذا
قيمه انه انا تولي غولدسن فما قصته
ولد انا تولي جولدسن في قريه اوكرانيه
صغيره عام
1926 ثم انتقل مع عائلته الى موسكو عندما
كان في السابعه لم يكن غوليتسن يحب ان
يطلق عليه لقب اوكراني مصرا على انه روسي
بالثقافه والتعليم حيث التحق بمدرسه
عسكريه وحصل على وسام سوفيتي للدفاع عن
موسكو في الحرب الوطنيه العظمى لحفر خنادق
مضاده للدبابات عندما كان في الخامسه عشره
انضم لحركه الشباب الشيوعي ثم اصبح عضوا
في الحزب الشيوعي مع بلوغه التاسعه عشره
في عام
1945 التحق بمدرسه مكافحه التجسس العسكري
قبل ان ينضم الى جهاز المخابرات السوفيتي
ويكمل مسيرته التعليميه داخل الجهاز حيث
انتسب للمدرسه العليا للدبلوماسيه
ثم التحق بمعهد الكي جي بي لدراسه القانون
اثناء دراسته شارك جولدسن مع صديق في وضع
اقتراح لاعاده تنظيم المخابرات السوفيتيه
فحضر اجتماعات عليا من اهمها اجتماع
للامانه العامه برئاسه ستالين واجتماع
لهيئه الرئاسه برئاسه مالينكوف كما عمل
لفتره وجيزه كرئيس لقسم مكافحه التجسس ضد
الولايات المتحده
بعد تخرجه عمل جولدسن محللا كبيرا في قسم
النيتو في اداره المعلومات بجهاز
المخابرات السوفيتي ما منحه فرصه للاطلاع
على الكثير من تقارير العملاء المزدوجين
وغيرهم ممن وظفتهم
لاختراق بيانات الغرب رغم ذلك لم يشعر
جولدسين باهتمام مرؤوسى وعانى من نظرتهم
اليه كضابط صغير وغير متميز وشخص مغرور
ومتمرد فيما ظنه هو انه يستحق مكانه افضل
كذلك عندما غزا السوفيتي المجرى في عام
1956 راى غوليتسن ان السياسه الشيوعيه
الجديده عدوانيه وبعيده المدى في عام
1961 تم تعيينه بالسفاره السوفيتيه
بفنلندا كنائب مستشار وملحق تحت اسم ايفان
كاليموف لكنه وفي ديسمبر من العام نفسه ان
ولجا الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حيث
نقل للاقامه بمزرعه قريبه من واشنطن خضع
جوليتس لاختبارات المخابرات الامريكيه
وعرضت عليه مجموعه من الوثائق لم يحتاج
لاكثر من نصف ساعه ليميز الحقيقيه منها عن
المزيف وحينها ادهش مستجوبيه بانه اطلع
عليها مسبقا عن طريق عملاء للسوفييت ما
اكد ان المخابرات الغربيه كانت مقترقه
فعليا
قدم جولدسين معلومات مهمه عن وثائق سريه
كمنظمه معاهده شمال الاطلنطي ثم بدا
بالكشف عن العملاء المزدوجين مثل كيمثل
وجاي برجس وجون فاسيل والكسندر كوبوتسكي
وغيرهم منذ عام
1962 وجوليتسن يدرس الشؤون الشيوعيه
والدوليه ويطالع مستجداتها بالصحافه وهو
ما ساعده على تقديم مذكرات تحليليه
للمخابرات الامريكيه لفتره امتدت لاكثر من
30 عاما تنبا فيها بالكثير حول تطور
الاستراتيجيه السوفيتيه الروسيه الشيوعيه
اضافه الى هدم جدار برلين وانهيار
الامبراطوريه السوفيتيه وصعود نظام
ديمقراطي في روسيا
في الفترات الاخيره تراجعت قيمه جولدسن
عند المخابرات الامريكيه كما كانت شخصيته
المتمرده محطه انتقاد من مسؤوليها لدرجه
ان اتهموه بجنون العظمه لكن جهوده قدرت
ومنح وسام حكومه الولايات المتحده للخدمه
المتميزه وعين قائدا فخريا للامبراطوريه
البريطانيه وبعد ان كان يتغنى بروسيته
اصبح مواطنا امريكيا متى انا طولي جولدسن
في عام 2008 وخلد افكاره في كتابين عن
السياسه البلشفيه وهما اكاذيب جديده
للقديم نشر في عام
1984 وخداع البروسترويكا مذكرات الى وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه في عام 1995